the conservatory of the fine arts over
at faith lutheran has a phantom on their
hands
of the opera that is they're putting on
the andrew lloyd webber classic this
weekend they did it last weekend here to
talk about eric ball he's the head of
the theatrical arts department over at
faith and madison smith she is playing
christine so first of all
congratulations on a successful first
weekend thank you very much so we have a
chance for folks to catch the closing
weekend yeah we have three more shows
friday and saturday at 7 p.m and sunday
at 4 p.m so talk about the putting on a
show of this magnitude over there at
faith well we always have um
directors i can you can imagine have a
challenge every year of what show to do
and we have a particularly talented uh
group of students this year and so we
thought if we were going to challenge
ourselves what better way to do it than
uh you know especially post pandemic
when everyone's taking their masks off
how about put a mask back on and do the
phantom of the opera
and so we uh we really really buckled
down we have an amazing creative team a
lot of people who put a lot of effort
into this one and and we we churned out
something i think is pretty special okay
so madison before we get to you i know
that there was a performance of a
production of the phantom on the strip
and they went all out with a chandelier
and you're telling me that you guys have
done the same thing yes we'll be
dropping a chandelier on the stage for
sure and we have a whole bunch of bells
and whistles on this one we kind of
pulled out all the punches okay so
madison let's go to you now do you know
how many other members you have in the
cast is it a pretty big group yes very
big we have about 35 to 40 members in
the cast it's very big and uh you're a
senior this year and you have a bright
future ahead of you where are you going
to be going i'm going to berkeley
college of music in boston which i'm
super excited yeah so tell me about
preparing for this role i mean it's not
an easy role yeah no so um
you know being able to just practice
every single day go through the songs
every single day do your lines every
single day it's really important to keep
that stamina up especially doing a role
so demanding and challenging knowing
that you can do that every single day
and stay solid and keep yourself healthy
and just really taking care of yourself
is the big thing and so you know the
young man who is playing the phantom was
it still scary to see the mask
a little bit on stage a little bit but
uh so if you had to give us just a line
or two from a song did you give us a
quick sample yeah of course
angela hear you speak i listen stay by
my side guide me
angel my sword was weak forgive me
enter at lust
master and i think that's enough
otherwise the phantom will actually show
up yeah we don't need we don't want that
but if you want to see the fandom go
over to faith lutheran this weekend
right and you can get tickets at
faithconservatory.com awesome eric ball
thank you so much madison smith thank
you thank you so much for having us oh
it is a real thrill to have you guys
here have a good luck with the run i
might try to catch the show myself thank
you